en su visita a la portuaria ciudad de
orán el presidente francés estuvo en una
tienda de discos símbolo de la música
rai antes de disfrutar de un breve
espectáculo de breakdance un ambiente
relajado que difiere de los eventos del
viernes dedicados a reparar los tensos
lazos con la ex colonia francesa macro
no llegó a una disculpa oficial pero sí
anunció la creación de una comisión
destinada a arrojar luz sobre las
atrocidades cometidas en el pasado
colonial mohamed complacido de comisión
vamos a crear una verdadera comisión de
historiadores vamos a abrir todos
nuestros archivos de ambos lados las que
dos y le vamos a pedir que trabajen
sobre todo el período desde el comienzo
de la colonización hasta el final de la
guerra
en una reunión que duró varias horas los
líderes argelino y francés también
discutieron temas tan espinosos como el
de las visas que provocó una disputa
diplomática entre los dos países en
otoño pasado pese a mantener una postura
dura sobre la inmigración ilegal macrón
también se comprometió a ampliar la
recepción de estudiantes
ya tenemos 30.000 estudiantes argelinos
en francia- cada año este año ya hemos
recibido 8000 más lo que es una
oportunidad para nuestro país lo que
nosotros queremos es recibir esta
movilidad positiva a los estudiantes los
emprendedores los responsables de
políticas los investigadores los actores
culturales o deportivos que sean también
rigurosos en la lucha contra la
migración clandestina porque en el fondo
eso es lo que no se discute y por eso es
que la relación entre argelia y francia
se paraliza algunas veces la visita de
manuel macro no termina en argel con la
firma de un acuerdo bilateral que busca
dar pie a una asociación renovada con
argelia